foreign
post it says a black student's
allegations that she was targeted for
eating wild black at a private
Massachusetts College were deemed
unfounded according to investigation of
the incident
UMO uh Knute then a rising sophomore at
Smith college had claimed that all she
did was all all she quote did was be
black when a gender when a janitor
called Security on her when he found her
in a closed Lounge in July 2018.
a 35-page investigation carried out by
an outside Law Firm found no evidence of
discrimination
the findings were issued in October 2018
but not widely reported
the incident began when kenote was a
inside a cafeterian dormitory that was
reserved for a summer camp program for
young children
since students were not supposed to use
the area a cafeteria worker Jackie Blair
reminded her of that fact but then
decided to drop the issue a janitor who
was in his 60s had poor vision then
noticed a figure in the distance eating
in a closed off Lounge area uh and uh
and school guidance calls for employees
not to confront strangers on their own
to the janitor notified security about
the person who turned out to be canote
uh the outlet reporter that janitor who
reportedly later claimed he couldn't
tell the person's gender because it was
dark
told dispatchers that there's someone
sitting there lying down in the living
room
a security officer then drove over
engaged in a polite conversation
but this woman recorded it
and so she she was where she was not
supposed to be
and uh you had school
you know employees followed proper
protocol to enforce the rules what they
were supposed to do
you also have to keep in mind from their
perspective you know you've got a
stranger in this area where they're not
supposed to be as reserved for a summer
camp for kids
if they don't say anything
and allow that person to be there
and then you know if something happens
anything happens related to that that
person
well they're going to be in trouble for
that
you know they might be liable for that
so they enforce the rules and um
and the woman claimed that it was racism
no basis for that claim whatsoever this
is back in 2018 the media ran with it
everyone ran with it went viral online
you may I vaguely remember this when it
first happened hearing a something like
this
um and of course you know as a rational
person when I first heard the story
I immediately thought
why is there any evidence that this is
race-based at all
obviously there wasn't
and um but
even so uh a lot of the people involved
with this the janitor was placed on
leave the following day I mean people
lost their jobs people were smeared
um across the media as being racist
these are normal and you're talking
about janitor at a school these are
normal Working Class People totally
innocent who were smeared libeld um
you know defamed as racist had their
lives ruined had their careers ruined
lost their jobs
all because of this
all because of this lie
from this despicable person who was
looking for attention
you know for her that's all she was at
she's at this fancy College everything's
everything's going well in her life her
life's gonna be fine
but she wanted a little bit of attention
she wanted some attention on social
media she wanted to get some Facebook
likes and some retweets
and for that just for that sake she was
willing to destroy the lives of however
many people didn't matter to her
about what a what a sociopath you have
to be
for such little reward you're willing to
completely destroy innocent people
speaking of Lies reports last week about
racist graffiti the good old racist
graffiti Gambit
um
racist graffiti found around campus at a
college called Albion College in
Michigan the graffiti said here's the
graffiti said
um KKK white power
die n-words please
and um
we do exist KKK
and then there was a star of David with
the numbers 666 written across I guess
it's supposed to be an anti-semitic
thing
um now this was a big deal locally got a
lot of attention the students protested
we got some footage of that they're a
pretty long line of them this is a small
college but looks like they all came out
look at them all all marching they all
came out to March
Against Racism on campus
uh and then what is it I don't I don't
have to tell you what happens next do I
you already know you heard racist
graffiti and if you if you've been
paying attention at all over the last 10
years you know exactly where this is
headed it was a hoax it was a black
student that wrote the graffiti
you know even without the the history
even without knowing the history you
probably would have already guessed that
this is a hoax
because this just isn't KKK white power
who do you think is is going to
sincerely write that
even if it was an actual white racist
like why would they write that
as we've covered many times you know
people who want to invent hate crimes
and turn themselves into a victim
they have they have a lot of trouble
doing it persuasively and convincingly
because they really have not encountered
a lot of racism from white people so
they don't even know what that would be
like they you know if if if
racism from white people was common in
this country number one you wouldn't
have to invent it
you wouldn't have to make it up
and number two if you did make it up you
would have encountered it so often that
you should be able to make it up and
impersonate it convincingly
but this is obviously someone who has
never encountered a white racist in his
entire life he has no idea what a right
white racist would say which is good by
the way he's never encountered one
that's a great thing we should celebrate
that
so instead he bases it off of like
movies that he saw in TV shows and stuff
that's one way that you know that it's a
hoax and the other way you know it's a
hoax is that as far as I can remember
and correct me if I'm wrong
at least say this I cannot think in the
last 20 years I cannot think of a single
case
where so-called racist graffiti or a
racist note left on a receipt or left on
someone's car windshield or slipped
under their door
um turned out to be sincere
every single case that I can think of
they were all hoaxes has there been even
one real case
I'm assuming just a law of averages
there have to have been right the last
20 years after have been at least a
couple
um of these racist graffiti cases that
was actually done by a white person
Maybe
anyway MLive has the report says Albion
College and the Albion Department of
Public Safety says that a student is
responsible for racist graffiti found in
a dorm last weekend
Albion police brought the 21 year old
blackmail in for questioning on April
6th the student admitted to creating
most of the graffiti and video evidence
from albion's campus safety department
confirms the statements made by the
student so I I take it from that that he
was on a security camera footage they
said video evidence confirms it so
I'm assuming that he that probably he
was right in front of a
of security camera scrolling this thing
when it comes to hate crime hoaxes
they're really not sending their best
um but here's the response to this from
Albion College and I could be
pronouncing the name of the college room
never heard of them before no but here's
what they tweeted this is this they put
they put this I think was yesterday this
is after it was already known who was
responsible for this and this is their
tweet okay
they said
earlier today we identified the
individual responsible for the racist
and anti-semitic graffiti in Mitchell
Towers
the student who was acting alone
acknowledged our responsibility for
these at for these incidents they had
been immediately removed from campus and
placed on temporary suspension while we
conduct a full investigation as part of
our student judicial process
but we know the acts of racism that have
occurred this week are not about one
particular person or one particular
incident we know that there's a
significant history of racial pain and
Trauma on campus and we're taking action
to repair our community
we will change and heal together as a
community because we are committed to
doing the work
right now we encourage all members of
our community to listen respond and care
for one another and lean on the faculty
staff community members who have been
Gathering today to make sure we're
supporting you we have your back okay
aside from the normal tribe about we'll
do the work
we're committed the phrase do the work
has become to me as grating and annoying
as the phrase lived experience and
they're always said by that usually in
the same sentence
um by the the same sorts of people
I'm surprised lived experience didn't
appear in this statement here we'll do
the work to understand your lived
experience
but do you notice so we got to do the
work we got the buzzwords and everything
you notice what's missing from this
statement
they never say it was a hoax
they never say that it was a black
student who did it
in fact they intentionally give the
impression that it was a white student
they don't say that
but they tie all this in to Historic
racism racial trauma
so on and so forth
they're clearly trying to give the
impression without saying it that the
graffiti really was done by a white
racist
that's the way the school has decided to
handle it
and um if that doesn't work then they
will
um at least try to disperse the blame
you know it's we're not going to blame
this one individual uh we're gonna blame
the institutions
this this is not this is not about one
particular person
it's about a history of racial pain no
it is definitely about one particular
person it's about the guy who did it
a guy who they say is kicked off a
campus that's good he should also be
charged with a crime
you know a hate crime hoax
is a hate crime
I'm not a fan of the hate crime
designation at all I don't think it
should exist but as long as it does it
should be used equally and in a way
that's at least sort of coherent and
what that means is that a hate crime
hoax should be considered a hate crime
so it's it is a hate crime against the
group of people that you're trying to
frame
that's when it's a hate crime against
so a black student putting that graffiti
up pretending that a white racist did it
that is a hate crab against white
students
he is trying to inflame hatred towards
the white students
and guilt by association is trying to um
to you know uh
defame them as as racist
that's the way we should that's why
these things should be handled
all right this is from the New York Post
it says Stanford University has launched
a hate crime investigation after a noose
was found hanging from a tree at a
residence hall in an email to students
and staff University officials said
campus safety authorities immediately
removed the Noose and retained it as
evidence
um the uh but official what the
university says we cannot State strongly
enough that a noose is a reprehensible
symbol of anti-black racism and violence
that will not be tolerated on our campus
it is the moral responsibility of those
with any knowledge of this incident to
come forward
now I'm only reading this story because
I want to go
usually I ignore these stories until it
is inevitably revealed that it's a hoax
so I just I'm gonna go on the record
right now and say this is either a hoax
now this is there's there's two
possibilities
um
one is that it's just a straight up hoax
probably most likely one the other one
is that and and often we find in these
kinds of stories it turns out that it
was uh you know it's like a tire tire
swing that somebody misinterpreted or a
garage door pull famously like at NASCAR
somebody go on the record right now and
I give it about a week until we get the
we get the meek quiet sort of little
update from the police saying oh yeah it
turns out that uh never mind just forget
about this whole story
and despite the fact despite the fact
that these hoaxes are so common
that when you read the story you already
know for near a hundred percent
certainty that it is a hoax
despite that
when they find the quote noose uh the
statement immediately says oh it's a
symbol of anti-black racism
I ask again that has there actually been
a real authentic case in the last
in this Century in this Century has
there been a real authentic case of a of
an anti-black racist a white person
hanging a noose somewhere as an as a
symbol of racism has has that happened
at all anywhere this century
I'm not aware of a single case of it
and I highly doubt that this incident at
Stanford in California will will be the
uh the first such authentic example
in in the past Century at least
but one thing we can be sure is that the
FBI federal government they're gonna be
on the case here
they sent what was it 20 agents to
investigate the garage door pull and
Bubba Wallace's garage so how many are
they going to send to Stanford
while they have crazed mobs violating
federal law and hunting down Supreme
Court Justice uh they don't have time to
deal with that they're going to be over
in Stanford looking into this tire swing
or you know
whatever it was
[Music]